all right so listen up Republicans are
going to try or better said they are
trying to steal that Kentucky
gubernatorial election that they lost
which I told you about yesterday by the
way big interest in my story yesterday
about the big wins by Democrats on
Tuesday evening in a bunch of different
state and local elections usually the
stories where I talk about local and
state elections and the implications
they just don't do that well but I got
dozens of emails from yesterday's close
to a hundred thousand views on YouTube
and just like the first twelve hour so
this is a good sign that people are
engaged with the races that are going on
so one of those races was the Kentucky
gubernatorial race in Kentucky very red
state which Donald Trump won by 30
points over Hillary Clinton in 2016
had a Trump loving governor named Matt
gubenatorial candidate named Matt Bevin
a major Democratic victory has taken
place with Democratic challenger Andy
Beshear the Attorney General of the
state knocking out the incumbent
Republican governor now this is Kentucky
it's not a blue state it's not a purple
state and officially at this point in
time it is a blue victory in a very red
state by 5189 votes for Andy Beshear the
Republicans are going to fight to the
end to steal the election and here's how
they're going to do it first of all as a
mere formality the governor has refused
to concede now again as I've said before
concessions don't really do anything but
later on it can be pointed to to try to
build the case that they from the
beginning didn't believe that they had
actually lost okay because of the small
margin they are going to demand that the
entire state be re canvassed as it's
called because of concerns that they are
generally talking about regarding voting
irregularities now the thing is they're
not telling us what those irregularities
are they say quote we want the people of
Kentucky to have absolute confidence
that their votes were counted as they
should have been counted but there's no
indication about why someone would
suspect that their vote was not counted
and there's also no specific claims or
evidence that have been presented that
anyone's votes were not counted
particularly in a way that would have
hurt the Democratic
or help the Democratic candidate as
counted but would help the Republican
candidate if they had been counted the
correct way but the whole point of all
of this is not even to get the
recanvassing to change the results
because it is very unlikely that
recanvassing would flip 5189 votes which
is the margin of victory so what's the
real point here the point is they want
to escalate the entire process to the
state legislature which is controlled by
Republicans because section 90 of the
Kentucky Constitution says quote
contested elections for governor and
lieutenant governor shall be determined
by both houses of the General Assembly
according to such regulations as may be
established by the law so understand
that all of this is premise on supposed
voting irregularities which were not
reported on Election Day and which the
Republicans refused to actually give us
any examples of Boerne is furious saying
quote in a democracy we cannot allow
politicians to just overrule election
results the the will of the voters must
be respected now this is a very long
shot especially since even if the state
legislature does get to decide they
still need to establish some fixed
process for how it's all going to be
carried out it's not just they pick the
winner and they pick the Republican but
it is still a last-ditch effort and they
are extraordinarily desperate and the
most likely way I'm guessing that they
would try to make some kind of progress
is to make some kind of argument about
the Libertarian candidate supposedly
getting two percent of the vote and
that's larger than the margin of victory
for the Democrat and they will probably
try to say there is you know there were
there were votes credited to the
libertarian that were meant for the
Republican or whatever I mean I mean
none of this stuff makes any sense I'm
just thinking ahead to what they're most
likely to do if it sounds absurd and
ridiculous to you it's because it is
absurd and ridiculous but they don't
care the means always justify the ends
if it keeps a Democrat out of office
even if the Democrat won
so we're going to be watching this one
very closely there's a lot of coverage
about this one on common dreams DailyKos
and a lot of other activist lefty
websites it's on Bernie Sanders radar so
hopefully it will not lend itself to a
situation where Republicans can actually
pull this off but they are furious they
see what Tuesday night's election
results potentially mean for them in
2020 they see what it means to start
losing state houses and governor's
mansions in red states across the
country Virginia turned totally blue
there were interesting results in some
parts of Pennsylvania that are
traditionally red that I did not get to
on Tuesday night which a lot of people
emailed me about and are important and
and we hopefully will get a chance to
talk about at some point so they see
what is going on whether they attribute
it to being damaged by Trump or not it
depends on which Republicans you talk to
some of them do some of them don't but
this is potentially going to be a
bloodbath in 2020 but I don't want a
single one of you to hear me say that
and believe that now you can rest on
your laurels and not have to work our
asses off for 2020 we could take the
Senate back it's an uphill battle but I
outlined how it could happen but it's
only if we really work in all of those
important states where there are
elections that could go from Republican
to Democrat we could knock out Donald
Trump but it's going to come down to
actually getting out the vote in those
key battleground states that I told you
about yesterday it could look really
good or it could be another four years
of a Republican Senate and Donald Trump
in the White House that's a real
possibility if we don't actually do what
we need to do